essentially sky news have actually
discovered that um
a couple of tory staffers um henry
dixon clegg and angus mcvean they wrote
a letter to boris johnson asking
essentially for the party to take
allegations of
bullying and sexual misconduct and all
those kinds of things a bit more
seriously they don't feel that perhaps
the party's doing enough when it comes
to protecting staff and so they kind of
went around other tory staffers to try
and get them to sign uh kind of co-sign
this letter with them however
turns out um you know in this letter
they call for uh they basically say
staffers are some staffers are
embarrassed for the culture in in
politics and in westminster and that
it's actually a kind of
an environment of fear and indifference
that's kind of fueling um the abuse
within westminster now what's really
interesting is sky news managed to see
some evidence of cchq conservative
campaign headquarters putting pressure
on tory staffers
to not sign this letter and essentially
staffers were told that there would be a
black mark against their name if they
were to sign this letter so really
concerning allegations there and here's
a clip from
the report that's going to be airing
later this evening
we're calling for a change partly in the
culture but also
the fact that these major allegations
fly around as just may gossip
and we thought that something had to be
said and we thought the staffers need a
voice this is our workplace as well and
we also wanted to create an environment
where colleagues can feel comfortable to
speak up
about experiences that they've had so
when you say staffers are being
discouraged from signing the letter
discouraged by who some staffers were
saying that they were concerned that
about the backlash that they would
receive all that their bosses would
receive
and some people were saying that these
messages were coming from cchq others
from the whips office so how many
staffers do you roughly reckon were put
off signing the letter there are a
significant amount of staffers that say
messaged us or spoke to us in person who
said that they weren't comfortable with
signing the letter but they agreed with
the contents of it we can't give you an
exact number but i'd say perhaps of the
people we did ask i'd say maybe 60 to 70
percent of people
so as you can see there really
concerning that potentially staffers are
being kind of made to be
potentially intimidated and not voicing
um concerns that they do have in their
own work environment now we did contact
cchq and the chief whips spokesperson
said that the chief whips been talking
with these staffers are very open to
discussions really really uh concerned
about their well-being
and um essentially kind of you know very
much kind of in discussions and have
introduced them to um the speaker
and other bodies to kind of get this um
resolved and to move forward with this
however i've been speaking to tory mps
one senior tour mp told me that uh
bullying and you know kind of bullying
behavior from mps to their staff is
really really common and very very
concerning and another tory mp said they
were amazed that more staffers hadn't
signed up and that it was really quite
shameful from the party
right and briefly these two more mps
putting in letters calling for uh boris
johnson to go
yes exactly so we've got uh elliott
cobin uh torrey mp and he has said he
sent in a letter but also we've got
jeremy wright former tenor attorney
general sorry um saying that they
essentially he wants the the prime
minister to resign so again more
pressure on boris johnson post-party
gate more pressure on the conservative
party to potentially rethink their
strategy and rethink their leadership
the only issue is even if there were to
be this no-confidence vote we know you
know the kind of dreaded 54 number of uh
letters going into segregate and brady
if that does hit the threshold boris
johnson will be sweating however it
doesn't mean he will necessarily lose
that confidence vote that would still be
up in the air but obviously a big
concern to the prime minister the other
thing is tories aren't yet united on a
specific candidate that they would love
to you know replace boris johnson and
that is also going to be playing in tory
mp's minds when it comes to putting
those letters in and having a strategy
were they to perhaps oust boris johnson
one day